>> I WILL GIVE IT TO THE
ANTETOKOUNMPO BOYS.
DID I SAY IT RIGHT?
>> YES, YOU DID.
>> THE ANTETOKOUNMPO BOYS.
THEY ARE OUT THERE.
THEY DON'T GET MUCH SHINE.
THEY ARE PLAYING WITH THEIR
BROTHERS.
I THINK THEY WANT TO INTRODUCE
THE WORLD TO WHO THEY ARE.
>> I WOULD ROOT FOR THEM.
>> I AM GOING WITH THEM.
>> I AM GOING WITH TEAM ROOKIE.
>> I'M GOING WITH TEAM CAVS.
THE GUYS PLAYING IN FRONT OF THE
HOME FOLKS.
>> THEY HAVE BEEN DOING TOO
MUCH.
>> THAT MAN GOT THE BEST JOB
SECURITY IN THE HISTORY OF
CIVILIZATION THERE.
WHO IS THAT?
THANASIS ANTETOKOUNMPO.
>> WHY?
>> SHAQ IS RUBBING OFF ON YOU.
>> AS LONG AS HIS BROTHER IS THE
MAN, HE IS GOING TO HAVE A JOB.
HE IS GOING TO HAVE A JOB.
>> NOT A BAD PLAYER.
>> I DIDN'T SAY HE WAS A BAD
PLAYER.
>> JOB SECURITY.
>> JOB SECURITY, THAT BOY IS
ALWAYS GOING TO HAVE A BROTHER
AS LONG AS HIS BROTHER IS THE
MAN.
>> IS THIS ABOUT THE ONLY THING
YOU HAVEN'T DONE ON ALL-ST